- Hello, and welcome to Ed Talks,
where we at Khan Academy talk to folks
who are influential in
the field of education.
I'm Kristen DiCerbo,
the chief learning officer
here at Khan Academy.
And I am happy today to welcome Ben Riley,
who is with Deans for Impact.
And we'll talk a little bit more about
what that organization
is and what it means,
but think about, we want to
talk about how we can embed
what we know about learning,
what we know from learning
science about how people learn
and how we can help teachers
use that in their classrooms.
So before we get started,
I want to remind you that Khan Academy
is a non-profit organization,
and we're able to keep doing our work
because of donations from folks like you.
So if you have the means
and you go to khanacademy.org/donate,
you will find a place where
you can help us continue
with our mission, thank you very much.
And I also want to recognize
some of our COVID crisis supporters,
including AT&T, General Motors and Fastly.
Thank you for your support.
One final thing before we get started,
if you want to revisit
some of these conversations
in audio form, we do have a podcast,
Homeroom with Sal, The Podcast
that you can find wherever
you get your podcasts,
and you can enjoy listening
to some of our conversations.
And we will jump right in
now to talking to Ben Riley,
Ben, welcome and thank
you for joining us today.
- Thanks for having me, Kristen.
- Excellent.
So I like to start off
with just talking to people
about how they got to
where they are today.
So I know in your background,
you've got some different
paths that maybe aren't typical
for folks that are in education.
Tell us a little bit
how you got to wind up
in the field of education.
- Sure.
So I come from a family
of public educators.
My grandmother was a school psychologist.
My mother was a school teacher
and then a school librarian,
and then a school counselor.
My father was a neuroscientist
and a professor.
So education was everywhere in my family.
And as a consequence, I
wanted nothing to do with it.
My whole plan with my life was
to do something entirely
different from that.
And through a circuitous route,
I ended up getting a law degree.
And even though I didn't
want to be a lawyer either,
I ended up working for the
California Department of Justice.
And within that, I started
working on lawsuits
brought against the State of California
for issues related to education policy.
And maybe it was in the blood.
Maybe it was something
about being surrounded
by educators my whole life,
but the questions that were
raised in those lawsuits
were profoundly interesting to me.
And so I quickly became
pretty heavily involved
in the issues related to
California education policy
that were hotly contested at the time.
Charter schools,
should every eighth grader
be taught algebra or not,
should testing be only in
English or in multiple languages,
a lot of hot button issues.
And then there were policy
matters that started happening
like race to the top and
president Obama wanting
to change education policy
throughout the 50 states.
And soon to be governor
again, Jerry Brown asking me,
"Is it a good idea, is it a
bad idea, what's your view?"
And so that kind of sucked
me into education issues
and I felt a bit hamstrung
being an attorney
where I was forced to
sort of take the position
of the State of California,
which wasn't always what I
necessarily personally believed
and aligned with and through
a bunch of circuitous routes
that I won't belabor,
I ended up becoming really interested
in how to improve teaching
and teachers in particular.
And so what I always
say when I speak is that
I don't have a background as a teacher.
I wouldn't pretend to be a teacher,
but I have spent my life as an advocate
and I am an advocate for
teachers and for great teaching.
And so that's what I've found myself doing
for most of my professional life.
- That's great, so my mom
was also a school librarian.
I've talked to other people in education
whose mothers are school librarians.
I think that's a powerful force
to have in your background
that kind of just gets you into these
and hooks you into these issues
and ideas that you wouldn't
expect to come back to.
So that's excellent, so based
on that, let's just talk,
tell me a little bit about
what Deans for Impact is
as an organization and what
prompted you to found it.
- Yeah, so Deans for Impact is
a national nonprofit organization
dedicated to ensuring
that every child has a
well-prepared teacher
and the story of our organizational life
is a little different, I think, than some
in that it didn't start out
with, at least from my end,
I had no intent of
starting an organization.
What happened was that
because of those interests
I mentioned earlier,
I started to get interested in like,
who are the leaders in
programs that prepare people
to be teachers, the deans of schools
of education, predominantly.
Who might be interested in trying
to transform and improve that process.
And I started to look
for them and found them,
and they started leading
me and mentioning others.
But what was fascinating is,
as I was talking to them,
it was very, very clear to me
that there was not any
connecting network amongst them.
And so I tried to bring them together
and just put them in a room.
This was going on 8, 9, 10 years ago
and say, "Okay, well, you know,
everybody in this room seems to agree
that we can do better in the
way that we prepare teachers.
What will it take to do that?
And what would an organization dedicated
to making that happen look like?"
And from that, Deans for Impact was born
and a big part of that, we
do a lot of different things,
but a big part of that has been trying
to strengthen the experiences that people
who are planning on becoming teachers,
the experiences that they have,
making them more meaningful and relevant
to classroom practice
and connecting to them
to our best scientific
understanding of how students learn.
And I would say that if there's anything
that I feel like was my contribution
to the Deans for Impact effort,
it was really focusing on
that piece in particular,
in part because I was stunned
to find out some years
into my career in education,
that there were all these
insights into how our minds work
and how we think and learn,
that I was not aware of.
And frankly, was working
on pursuing some projects
that looking back on it,
I might not have worked on
and pursued if I had known
the science of learning.
So we've made that a point of emphasis
and it continues to be something
we're working very hard at.
- That's actually how I
first came to be aware
of Deans for Impact was
the release of this science
of learning paper that laid
out in really clear language,
some fundamental things
that we know about learning from research.
Nice little footnotes
that give the reference
to where things are,
but that it's really accessible and easy
for people who haven't studied them
and don't have PhDs in education
to really grasp onto,
how did that come about
as you started thinking
about how to build that?
- Yeah, thanks for those kind words.
There were a couple of things
where I could almost say we got lucky,
but it was also a little bit by design
in putting the science of learning out.
And by the way, it's available
at the Deans for Impact website,
completely free of charge,
six pages, click download, you've got it.
And really it was born of the fact
that I knew we had a cognitive scientist
who thought a lot about
how to communicate ideas
of cognitive science to the general public
and Dan Willingham at the
University of Virginia is someone
who's written a lot of
books, a lot of blog posts.
And the reason I knew about--
- He's actually a previous Ed Talk guest.
- Okay, great, I will watch them
because I'm sure it was compelling.
I didn't even know that.
And that I think speaks to the fact
that Dan has spent a
non-trivial amount of his career
trying to get these ideas
in the hands of teachers.
So I knew on the science side,
we had a scientist who could think
how to communicate
effectively to non-scientists.
The flip side and this is I think a place
that's still underdeveloped
in education generally
is that there's an awful
lot of teachers out there
and wouldn't it be interesting
to have a teacher involved
in the creating of something
that's meant for teachers?
And so, through, again,
a time when blogging was
more common than it is now,
I had found this blogging
teacher named Paul Bruno,
based in California, middle
school science teacher,
who wrote often about education issues
and wrote very clearly and
had written in particular
about academic standards,
content standards,
and how some of the new
standards that were being drafted
weren't gonna be very useful to teachers
because they were getting
vaguer and vaguer.
And I thought, this is what we need.
We need to find something that
will tell teachers in ways
that don't make it just
completely like anything goes,
which is often, I think
the unfortunate by-product
of people being afraid to take a stand.
And yet at the same time, you don't want
to get so micro specific that it sounds
like you're being prescriptive
in how you are teaching.
And so we got Paul and
Dan together and said,
"All right, let's get to work."
And from that, the science
of learning was born.
- That's fantastic.
That point is really interesting
because often even researchers themselves
very much hedge their conclusions
or say, "Well, you know,
it might depend or in
this specific situation."
And getting from that to something
that is still actionable,
knowing that there's maybe
some caveats behind the scene,
but it gives teachers something
that is concrete for them to work on,
but doesn't get all the way
to "Do this exact thing",
that's a fine line to
walk and where things fit.
- It's hard to find that
sweet spot for sure.
And I think that education
generally, again,
sort of tends towards the nice,
and that's a good thing in general,
we're working with students,
we want to be nice,
but I think teachers
sometimes need something
that's more directly relevant
so that they don't have
to be spending, they've
got so much time to spend
on trying to think through all
the various things they need
to think through.
If you could make it
easier for them to see,
"Okay, this is how this
scientific principle connects
to specific teaching actions,
instructional decisions."
Then you sort of help
build the bridge, scaffold,
as we say, in education,
ideas from science to
their implementation,
their application in the classroom.
So I think that's an ongoing
and will never be a perfected challenge.
But I think that if you have,
again, teachers involved,
you're gonna be more
likely to get something
that teachers find helpful.
And also, hopefully you have scientists
who are able to think about how to make
that science translatable and
understandable to non-experts.
- That makes sense, that makes sense.
So in the research world,
sometimes we're starting to hear a lot
about brain science and brains,
but you've been vocal about
distinguishing between the brain
and the mind when it comes
to children's learning.
What's the difference between those two?
- Yeah, thank you for that question,
because I see this a lot
too, as you just said,
and there's conferences that are like
mind, comma, brain, comma blank.
And a lot of times people
will assume that like,
I'm really excited about neuroscience
and my dad was a neuroscientist.
I actually think neuroscience
is super fascinating
as a field and provocatively,
I actually don't think it's
that useful to teachers.
So let me back up and
answer your question.
The brain is an organ, right?
It exists inside our head
and there's no doubt that it exists.
It has all the different
pieces, the cerebellum,
the amygdala, and too
many other parts to count,
but it's there, it's a thing.
It's a physical object
that's part of our anatomy.
The mind is a metaphor.
The mind is a construct that
we use to try to make sense
of a lot of different
things that are going on.
Sometimes when I try to explain this,
I invoke another metaphor
or analogy to make this a
little bit more tangible.
So I'll try that out here.
If you think about a car
and what a car is supposed to do,
a car is supposed to transport
you from one spot to another,
the car has within it an engine.
We're gonna call that engine the brain.
And what I'm gonna say is
in order to operate your car
in ways that are meaningful
and useful to you,
you don't really need
to know hardly anything
about how that engine works.
What you do need to know
is how to drive the car,
driving is what matters.
And if you think about what
we mean when we say driving,
it actually consists of a
lot of different pieces.
It's putting your foot down on the gas
and shifting into gear
and turning and braking
and making decisions
about oncoming traffic.
Driving is the mind,
the mind is the driver and
the driving of cognition
and how we make sense of the world.
And so everything that I
think that is super important
for teachers to have at
least some understanding of
is how do I drive this thing?
And the thing really is the
minds of their students.
How do I get them to think about
what it is they need to think about
in ways that lead to durable
and lasting learning?
- That totally makes sense.
And I could probably go
on a whole other tangent
about the brain science piece.
I actually am very aligned with you,
the practicalities of
what it offers for folks
in classrooms and what they're doing.
But as you're thinking about what teachers
should know about how to drive
that car and how to do it,
I know that you also did some work
with some pre-service teachers,
teachers that are in
teacher training programs
to try to understand
what are they learning
and what do they know as they
go through those programs.
What were some of your findings there?
- Yeah, so before directly
answering that question,
I'll back up and say that
we referenced the science
of learning document
and that document sort of
has a series of questions
about how learning takes place.
How do we understand new ideas?
We, over time, sort of distilled those
into a set of principles
that come from the science of learning,
the science of cognition,
cognitive science.
And we used those as sort
of our basic framework
for figuring out what
it is that we both want
future teachers to know
and where do they start?
What do they know about how we learn
before anything has happened
vis-a-vis an engagement
with Deans for Impact, or frankly,
in any of the programs
that are preparing them
to become teachers.
And so we developed an assessment and we
actually looked around
to see if any assessment
like this existed already,
and it might be out there,
but we couldn't find it.
So one of our very able employees,
Dr. Rebecca Berlin came on board and said,
"No problem, let's get to work.
We'll build an assessment
around these learning science principles."
And so we did,
and then we asked a lot
of teacher candidates,
I think, a little over a thousand
to take the assessment
and give us just a sense
of where they were in their understanding
of learning science.
And there was a couple
of interesting findings.
You can go kind of glass half
empty, glass half full in that
when it came to sort of basic
understanding of cognition,
they got about half the questions right,
half of them wrong.
Now, you could say,
half right on a test is
usually no an A for sure.
And is usually tilted
towards the other end
of that spectrum, on the other hand,
they hadn't really been
exposed to a lot of it yet.
So, how much would you
expect them to know anyway,
if this hasn't been a
focus of their studies?
The other thing that I
thought was really interesting
with that is that there
was significant difference
between their understanding
of scientific principles
in the abstract versus
their understanding of how
to apply those principles when making
an instructional decision,
something that relates to the classroom.
And on those sorts of test
questions that we gave them,
they did a little bit
better, significantly better,
I would say, 10, 15
percentage points better.
So that was interesting
because it sort of suggests,
and I've come to believe this in my time
working in education, that
sometimes you don't necessarily
know why something works.
You just figure out that it works.
And I think when looking at
sort of making certain choices,
people who are preparing
to become teachers
are better able to figure out
"Well, yeah, I want to
do that with my students
rather than some alternative."
And they make a better choice there
than their basic understanding
of learning science might suggest.
So that was encouraging.
And in some ways we're trying to lift up
how future teachers do on both dimensions,
but it's really that latter dimension
that is applying these
principles in practice
where the real impact will be made.
Because if they are making those
sorts of choices correctly,
over and over again with their students,
it's more likely to
have this sort of impact
on student learning that
we're hoping to have.
So, some people can look at the data
and sort of have a negative takeaway,
but we view it the opposite
at Deans for Impact.
- Yeah, well,
it also somewhat laid out the case
for why your organization is needed.
People are doing okay on their own
and we need to think about
how to raise that up above
where it is, that makes sense.
I also wonder if some of the
results from education research
are kind of intuitive
and what we would expect.
And so if you're making
choices based on that,
it makes sense.
And then there's some other things
that maybe aren't as intuitive,
honestly, learning styles comes to mind
where you think like, "Oh yeah,
people have these different styles
and we should tailor instruction to that."
But the research doesn't
really support it.
And so maybe it's more of those kinds
of counter-intuitive
findings where you're seeing
if no one's ever been taught that,
then they aren't gonna know
where that intuition is.
Just kind of thinking about the results.
- I think you're right,
now, I'm gonna make it a
little bit provocative here,
'cause I'm gonna ask you a question.
So before we jumped on this,
I went and visited the
Khan Academy website,
which I hadn't been to in a while.
And like many, many places, I see sort of
a cry for personalized learning.
A sort of flag for personalized learning.
And in particular,
that students should control
the pace of their learning.
And look, you're not responsible
for what's put on a website, I know that,
but I wonder knowing what you
know about learning science,
do you think that's a good idea?
Because I think that's another thing where
that idea sounds so appealing.
Certainly philanthropists enjoy it.
I think a lot of parents enjoy it.
And provocatively, I
would say the evidence
as I understand it from
learning science would suggest
that actually novices,
students are in a poor position
to be regulators of their own learning
because they don't know
what they don't know.
And thinking is very difficult.
And they, when faced with something
that is cognitively challenging,
they may try to take the
path of least resistance
in order to get through that.
I mean, I certainly see this
a lot with students who just,
they just want to get the
answer right and move on.
And that's kind of built into
a lot of our education system.
So I wanted to ask you if
you are working internally,
if you have like internal conversations,
how do you think that situates
between learning science
and personalized learning?
- First, love it.
Thank you for asking.
So we have tons of
conversations about this.
So the foundational
thing that Khan Academy
is really based on is the
idea of mastery learning.
And so the idea of mastery learning,
working at something until you
have that high level of
proficiency before you go on
to the next thing that you're working on,
that is pretty well supported.
There's meta-analyses and
meta-analyses, and meta-analyses
that support that idea
of mastery learning.
And the key thing about
mastery learning is that
it's pretty antithetical to
moving at a lockstep pace
in a classroom because it's just,
students are gonna have different gaps
that they need to fill in.
Some students are gonna
take longer on this concept
to really master it.
Then the students who are gonna take
longer at this concept.
So that idea of pacing
and students maybe being
at different paces is
really an artifact for us
of the idea that we want
students to get to that idea
of mastery and really build
proficiency on a skill
before they try to build
something on top of that skill,
with that shaky foundation
of where things are.
So there's that piece of it.
And then the second question is,
okay, that's kind of that
personalized piece of,
everyone's not gonna be
moving at the same pace
through this content,
you're gonna move at
different paces depending
on what you're doing.
And then the question is
who controls that pace
and who controls what's doing?
So I think, what I pushed for is actually,
there's a kind of a triangle of teacher,
the system and the learner.
And both, depending on
a student's proficiency,
depending on their developmental stage,
depending on where they
are, we want to be changing
that portion of who's
doing what over time.
And when we're starting out with novices,
when we're starting out
with young learners,
it's gonna be more teacher directed.
And when we have teachers who
have 30 kids in a classroom,
there's some benefit to having
the system do a little bit
of guidance too, that
we can build into that.
Over time, ideally we want learners
to end up being lifelong
learners who are able
to control and regulate
their own learning,
but they're not gonna be
there from the beginning.
So it's more of a journey
and that self-regulated
personalized learner is the goal,
but not where we're
gonna be all at the time.
So that's kind of where we
are, does that make sense?
- No, it makes sense.
And I think, look,
I can be that rude guest
who's sort of invited on
and then like lobs little criticisms,
but I understand where
you're coming from with that.
I would say that like, the mastery point
is an interesting one because we could,
offline or in a perhaps
future Ed Talk talk about
various readings of the research.
I think it's really hard to know
what mastery is of anything.
And I think one of the key
insights of learning science
that's really, really hard
to build into any education
platform, education system
is that you're unlikely to remember
most of the information
you're ever exposed to
at any one time.
And you've got to come back to it
and anybody who's ever
crammed for a test knows
that you're able, at a point in time,
to perform as if you
have learned something,
AKA perhaps from certain
dimensions, develop mastery of it.
But if it hasn't actually
changed your long-term memory,
i.e. what it is that you
store as your knowledge,
then you haven't gained that mastery.
And I'm sure Khan Academy doesn't do this,
but there are a lot of other platforms
where mastery means take a
quiz at the end of something.
And if you score above a certain thing,
then you've demonstrated mastery
and on you are to the next subject.
So I think that's an area where, sort of,
I would love to see more
technology enthusiasts
in education have a deeper understanding
of what learning science says or suggests.
- Well, I cannot let that just lie there
because in Khan Academy, we in
fact have mastery challenges.
So initially you take a quiz
and get some level of proficiency,
but then after a period of time,
you'll have a mastery challenge comes up
that's going to bring back
skills from previous things
that you have achieved initial mastery at
and give you some more
questions about those,
doing that spaced practice,
that kind of spiral review.
Absolutely, because of
all of that research,
it's not just a one time, you're done,
but there's a forgetting curve
and you need to think about
how to help learners keep that
information fresh over time.
So we absolutely are thinking
about that in what we do, too.
- Great, I'm glad to hear it.
- That said, I'm gonna pivot us back
so you can tell a little
bit more about what you do.
I appreciate it, thought,
I love this conversation.
So in thinking about teacher
preparation programs,
how do you go about working
with different schools
and bringing them together?
- Yeah, sorry if I hijacked the interview,
but I'd like this to be bilateral
rather than just one-sided.
So we do a lot of different
things with schools of education
and leaders in school of education,
but per the conversation we're having now,
the thing that we do is bring
together networks of programs
that want to embed learning science
into what we sometimes
call the arc of experiences
that a teacher candidate,
someone who's preparing to
become a teacher goes through
from the very beginning
until the very end.
And that work takes like multiple years,
involves multiple faculty members
and typically the Dean of Education,
at least signing off on the project
and then really working hard
to both figure out what,
if anything, is being done presently
to get those ideas into the
heads of future teachers
and then figure out, well,
how can we do more of that
and how will we figure out
whether we've made improvement with that?
We have something now that we've developed
around sort of the six
principles that we have.
And I'll talk about those in
more particularity in a second here,
but we have sort of these
modules as we call them
where we sort of introduce a
concept from learning science,
set up a series of ways
of engaging with it,
not just read and regurgitate
back the principle,
but think about it in
the context of a variety
of different situations
that a teacher is likely
to encounter and then move towards a place
where both teacher educators,
the ones responsible
for preparing people to be teachers
and teacher candidates are
actually enacting and working
with other students or other humans
to actually apply the
principles in practice.
And then from that, getting feedback
and coming back and saying,
"Okay, did that work?
Did it not work?
Did you understand what
you were trying to do
and why it may have worked
or why it did not succeed?"
And now hopefully get feedback on that
so that you can go try it again
and hopefully practice and get better.
So that's the nature of the
work as mentioned earlier,
we're both assessing at the beginning,
throughout the whole
process and at the end
to see whether there's improvements.
And we have enough data now
since we started launching these networks
to see pretty dramatic improvements
in the areas where programs have focused.
And so, I'll pause there
if you have any questions about that,
but I can sort of talk
about a particular principle
that's become pretty focal
for a lot of programs
and sort of what that looks
like in the work that we do.
- Yeah, one of my questions,
to go back to this point
about mastering skills,
we're actually asking teachers
to master these skills
related to teaching,
based on learning science.
How do you think about
designing programs so that
it's not just, "Here's this
skill, here's the thing.
Okay, now we're moving
on to the next thing."
And keep it kind of woven through.
- Yeah.
I mean, this is the hard part,
and it's particularly hard
working with schools of education
that are inside institutions
of higher education,
universities, as we typically call them.
And the reason for that is,
is that if you think back to anyone
who's experienced college and university,
you had a bunch of courses, right?
And maybe they all added up to a major,
but each of the courses was sort of
project and owned by
whoever the professor was.
Or maybe the professor farmed
it out to some grad students
who then taught the class.
And so what you have
typically had is a series
of discrete things that don't braid
and do not interleave,
to use a term that comes
from learning science
that basically means just,
keep coming back and
weaving through ideas.
And don't just focus on
one thing and move on.
So what we try to do is bring together
all the people involved
in the whole arc of experiences,
again, as we call it.
And that means getting
together, tenured faculty,
non-tenured faculty, what
are called the adjuncts,
who are often sort of
hired on to do a lot of
sort of the practicum training.
It means bringing in,
and this is really hard,
bringing in the teachers
who are in K-12 schools,
who are involved in
mentoring the teachers.
So you've got to get everybody
at the table agreeing on,
agreeing on the importance
of embedding these principles
in all of the aspects of
preparing someone to be a teacher.
So it's hard work,
but it's also really amazing
work when it pays off,
because you can actually talk
to these teacher candidates
at the end of it, people who are often
21, 22 years old,
college seniors who are about to graduate
and the level of sophistication they have
in talking about their practice
and the confidence that they have
in sort of what sort of
teacher they want to be,
what sort of activities they
want to give to their students,
what sort of learning they
want to see take place,
their beliefs about the capabilities
of all of their students.
It's inspiring.
I mean, I know I'm biased,
but it's what gets up everybody
who does this work at Deans for Impact.
I think it's probably the
single biggest motivator for us.
So that's what it looks like
and that's what it takes.
- That sounds great.
We've already gone through our 30 minutes.
- What?
I didn't even get to talk about
specific principles, my bad.
I asked questions, I
shouldn't have done it.
- Do you have a couple of minutes?
- Yeah.
- We can do a specific principle?
Let's do that, go ahead
and let's talk about that.
- Well, I just wanted to
talk about one principle
in particular that I'd mentioned earlier,
that's proven to be
particularly important.
And I think there's a reason for that.
One of the six principles
from learning science
that we've articulated
is something we call deepening
meaning and learning,
and that's kind of vague and hazy,
but what we mean by
that is kind of simple.
And that is,
what is it that you want
your students to think about
and how will you design the experience
they have in your classroom,
so they think about that thing?
And let me give you a
very tangible example
and it kind of connects
to what I was just saying
about the inspiration
that comes from this work.
I just was on the phone
about a couple of weeks ago
with a soon to be teacher
in North Carolina,
who was doing part of her
teacher training in a school
in Charlotte and a veteran
12 year teacher asked her
to do a particular task
with her eighth grade science students.
And the task was get some
plaster of paris, roll it around,
take a plastic dinosaur, stick
it in the plaster of paris,
wait for it to dry and
now you have a fossil.
Now, that might be fun and
interesting to an eighth grader.
I have my doubts,
but what it won't do is teach
them anything meaningful
about how fossils get made.
And what was really remarkable is that
this soon to be teacher
could see all of this
and could say this isn't
the sort of thinking
that I want my students to do.
There are five different types of fossils.
I want them to understand
what the differences
between those five different
types of fossils are.
I want them to understand the differences
in what it takes to make those fossils.
I want them to understand what
different things we can learn
and know about our society today
because of those different
types of fossils.
This is someone, I don't
know exactly how old she is,
but she's a college senior.
And she's looking at
something that, unfortunately,
some 12 year veteran teacher
is thinking is a good activity
for eighth grade science
students and saying,
"Ah, not for me and not for
the students I'm gonna teach."
So that's the principle
that more than any other,
we have seen the programs
we're working with,
teacher candidates struggle, and frankly,
even sometimes teacher educators struggle.
And I think more than
just about anything else
in education broadly,
if we could get everybody involved
to really focus on the question,
what is it that is important
for students to think about
and how I get them to think about that
in ways that they will truly
learn it, to our earlier point.
I think nothing else could
be more transformative
to our education system and
to frankly, our citizenry.
I really do.
- I love that.
And I love that as a prompt for thinking
about technology in the classroom too,
because there's real limits
to what technology can do.
And Khan Academy really
ready to acknowledge that.
And it's really hard from our side
to know what students in the classroom are
actually thinking about.
So we can provide those
prompts and those activities,
but it takes the teacher in the classroom,
working with those
students, asking them why,
asking them what made you say that?
All of that to really understand
what students are thinking,
and if they're getting that meaning from
what the prompt was and
what those places were.
So really interesting.
- Yeah, you're totally right about that.
And I thank you for raising
it and at the same time,
I actually think there's a number
of ways in which technology,
when you have an understanding
of learning science
becomes really empowering,
because now you're not just
being told to use technology
by a superintendent who was sold something
by a vendor somewhere.
You're thinking about how will
this be something that leads
to the sort of learning I
want to have with my students.
And I didn't think I was
gonna tell the story,
because I haven't thought
about it for a while,
but I think it's befitting
our conversation.
One of the interesting
tools I've seen used
a little less so nowadays,
but there's tools that allow people
to become their own Sal Khan.
You can do sort of your
own little casting.
Well, there are some
brilliant teacher educators
and professional development specialists
who have taken to giving kids a tablet
and asking them to be their own Sal Khan,
as they're working through a problem,
and then they record it.
And then you have an
artifact that you can look at
that literally gives you sort of,
you can hear the student talking through,
you can see them doing the math equation.
You can see them erasing things,
and you can go back and
look at it and start to say,
"Okay, where was the misconception?
Where did that come in?
What were they thinking
when they did this?
Why do you think they did this?
What would you do as the teacher,
if you thought they were
having that misconception?
What would you do to
check if you were mistaken
about that misconception?"
So it's a way of saying,
if we get every kid to be like Sal Khan
with a little tablet, we might
be making some real progress.
(Kristen laughs)
- That sounds great, love it.
All right, I will ask to close.
For you to give us one note of optimism,
something that you see that's promising
or gives you hope in our current times.
- Yeah, well, I may have
already stepped on it
by mentioning that teacher,
soon to be teacher,
I was speaking to earlier,
but she's not alone.
There are so many teachers right now
who are starting to get
more and more interested
in these ideas from learning science
and it's global, it's global.
It's really a conversation
that's happening.
And we get inquiries from
teachers and teacher educators,
and policy makers from all over the globe.
And without exception,
their inquiries are always
about the science of learning
and what it means for their teaching
or for their education system.
And so there's a movement happening
and we're lucky to be part of it.
And I'm grateful for the chance
to have this conversation,
because I hope everybody
who's listening and watching
will take a peak and
start to get interested
in these ideas, if you aren't already.
- Great, thank you so much.
Thank you for the work you do.
And also for joining us
to talk about it today.
Loved the conversation.
Thank you and best wishes in the new year.
- Thanks so much, Kristen.
I really enjoyed it, thank you, again.